c'est un vendeur de boulettes à Tunis tu
veux parler meilleur boulette de Tunis
il vient d'ouvrir le stand et toute la
Tunisie vient pour manger ses boulettes
un jour il rencontre une meuf et il
tombe amoureux mais il apprend que le
père de cette filière radiologue donc ça
fout la fout mal de dire qu'il est
vendeur de boulettes il dit moi je suis
pharmacien j'ai quelques informations à
Tunis le lendemain la fille elle est
avec des copines elle a dit meuf il y a
un mec il a ouvert des boulettes un
petit stand de boulettes faut vraiment
qu'on y aille vas-y moi avec les copines
elle est le mec il est de dos comme ça
et la fille a fait bonjour monsieur je
pense ciboulette il fait ciboulette tout
de suite
comme ça il voit sa meuf il voit les
boulettes alors ça sera de matin de midi
et deux soirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]